that's actually not promoting us were so
full podcast were back for Game seven
yeah man well gigawatts all my chillin
watching it from the TV all excited I've
seen your TV dogs we did yeah dude right
behind the dog we got the dugout full I
was I was in Fort Leonard Wood right
when you do the show yeah Missouri I'm
doing those eight army bases uh-huh
I was doing like eight army bases and we
wanna go just go to the a bases get to
the bases yes doing an army base tour
this weekend November 4th
I'll be at Fort Rucker Alabama with
Seaton Smith and finesse Mitchell from
SNL see this man by the way
he was a token brother in their show um
Mulaney November 10th Fort Huachuca
Arizona November yeah man and then the
week after that up November 10th appear
in Fort Huachuca Arizona then I'm eating
the tour with four shows in a row
November 15 at Aberdeen Proving Ground
Maryland November 16th Fort Belvoir
Virginia November 17 Fort Hamilton New
York November 18 for drum
that's my Syracuse by the way if you
have an active military card you can go
to these shows or if you're an active
employee of the US Army like you work on
a base maybe you look at another base or
your reserve you're allowed to go to
these shows or or if anybody wants to go
to a show man start hooking up with army
officers right now and have them take
you to the or these shows there are some
shows there's three of us we're in and
out wait a minute no merch bro just in
there how is it all you guys been I'm
man first of all were two fort law Fort
Leonard Wood we got to the wrong spot
man this place is huge brawl at the
beginning of the entrances that they
were gate
you gotta command any credentials
there's a
the m16 ready to blast you rush in there
bro MP huh and you shove your ID and you
go in there and they have a hotel room I
hope they have it's like a whole city a
whole city like hotel rooms the
commissary to HUD everything and then
it's like 45 minutes long this town if
you could drive to the end of town he's
got 45 minutes there's a gate another
one just to get out no you can't get out
through there but just watching the gate
oh okay I'm patrol surrounded fool
myself when I got to Fort Leonard Wood
it was the first show there was a bunch
of armed air force people there right
they're all hanging out doing whatever
they were doing and then another one
showed up and then they leave it was in
charge of the show she told me were
there some people in there she said yeah
what are they do it in there protecting
me I guess I told her security because
they weren't out there just like
officers like you know camouflage uh-huh
we're gonna ask the word they're doing
their hell now I'm a guess they're in
the green room so wait
take whatever you want I go back and
then then it goes off I was fine they're
getting married what the getting married
but one of them was a captain and you
were marrying um this couple a hallway
bro really like just fast legal wedding
right there
give me a Mexican pizza to go we had
talked about we're gonna start something
about these people in the office people
getting a name maybe that ridiculous
Brewster elope right
elope like jitter oh they're a witness
and a bunch of people they got marry
right there that's what we agree to this
I said barracks oh that way they could
be what they're you know what they're
boo right they thought it was weird that
just got married like that like cuz
those barracks get all alone you need
your little your rib yeah sure they were
both there were both are Nam from the
Air Force but they never go into the
comedy show they were just gonna get
married in the green room and that was
it that was it should have celebrated on
some laughs yeah man it was far man
these places was like those like bases
I've never even heard of dude Fort
Leonard Wood was huge
and um I saw pizza that they delivered a
Pizza Hut to the hotel room and then
when I saw him I made a joke about him
because I know that everybody here from
the military or the people who are
civilians - then it's together civilian
oh good man cuz the guy who deliver the
pizza right now man he look like me
then I opened up with I was hard to find
drugs in here nearby laughs what's a lot
of foods out there bro like I met this
one fool who look like Stephen fly
what's up everybody I'm at the gate
already [ __ ] dawg I'm the mayor of
this old fort we come inside he telling
him he's not only the vice mayor bro
he's a city manager so I gonna see
rewrite it like once the mayor goes down
the city manager takes over right yeah
did it all you gotta trickles down dude
yeah man and we're in Fort Knox he's a
with the mayor important we went to Fort
Knox how's that I saw where the money is
kept the gold what is it
dude this is bunker what's up it's all
camo it's all like I'm with barbed wire
hardcore concrete building fortified and
then the bottom then the support they
said they said have you seen the money
let me show you the money if you seen
the gold let me show you the gold I'll
show you a faint one so it's like he
couldn't go they know where you're gonna
take a civilian or anybody 300 feet on
the ground
supposedly a 300 feet under the ground
yeah you probably need a mat securely
I'm going 300 feet does he share dog do
you testing down there and stuff like
that to do so I'll leave this army bases
are all full training brought to be like
a battle yeah I met a guy named Rodrigo
Rose
regal regal Rodrigo whatever his name
was he let your chosen Tonio I'm talking
about that shut up and I asked her what
did you do wrong for that could I work
you're making hot dogs right now bro
what'd you do in the world 350 fires are
making hot dogs army base with a skinny
ass who blow the lid off he did a
redneck foot it was a firecracker feed
him he was oh man I was a photographer
during the war do it for the army
what yeah I shot
we're talking for doing bad oh man I'm
around the first Gulf War Grenada Panama
ooh I named all the places yeah so they
were shooting you were shooting a camera
yeah been around he goes did you shoot
back with my camera he did funny my like
some people are fighting you know these
army guys are fighting you know whatever
battle they're fighting but this is all
a guy they're fighting for the for the
history oh yeah that's we documented
on the under a war legal war are you
allowed to shoot photographers and
paramedics no I don't think so I think
this part of like Geneva Convention
stuff but I don't know is that but in
guerrilla warfare vol IV huh anybody who
cares that you're allowed to shoot
together walkie talkie take it you'd
figure out where is that that's crazy
man so ma'am are these fools man
those are food with a war so full
podcast winner are you serious yes sir
on him bro forgot your name already but
yeah man that's awesome that he was in
Fort Knox or fort no Fort Leonard Wood
Missouri with a were so full podcast
hoodie though yes Danny madly represent
he dude what up dude the hotel broke
Cavs are in there oh yeah you could be a
civilian working there but you need
extra pass so you just get in there and
all I said yeah we went when we went to
on Fort Knox the gate we had we had an
escort but he was not out he was not a
part of that watching fool it was some
Latino guy right his mom is Mexican and
I fooled up bragging about this $86,000
home he bought damn after Missouri with
eight acres 86,000 yeah you keep that
[ __ ] dog yourself what you call balling
over there huh yeah but I get a lot of
work over there if you could get up
credentials to get up in the basement
work it's funny that you mentioned uh
Steven fighter on the war was going on
and Gannett and he's a dog you know they
they paying fifty six thousand dollars a
year just to scoop food in the war
this is like a line cook so that
photographer does what he does but he
works he works full-time with a
photographer somewhere in town
yeah the home there in Texas and he was
part-time job there in the base because
he's two military so two to two jumps
photographer and he cooks hot dogs all
day all night so I'm talking about to
chain to pay them in ways that much hell
yeah dude cuz I'm thinking they have
levels right yeah they're a bowling
alley in Fort Knox a bowling alley a
movie theater a hotel Pizza Hut some
restaurants clothing stores bank it's a
town bro everything it's a town but that
town's under lock and key huh oh yeah
bus curfew they handed parties boys I
don't know their party about inviting
Chynoweth finesse Mitchell bro what's up
they'll run into the airport one time
with skills
that's right skills Hudson don't eat my
head off
yeah man so yeah brah so I'm in Fort
Leonard Wood bro chilling you know sober
uh-huh I had nothing and then I get a
email on Instagram working a week any
yeah so Joe Lopez I'll be working on
weekend I said yeah I'm at some military
base on here I'm supporting the troops
aleem goes up because I never extra
ticket to the World Series broke Game
five
oh yeah I have to do it get over there
bro get a hotel take the Blackhawk dog
and I was probably I think I was gonna
take I'll take Air Force One but I'm
president trouble you venir at the time
that 15 yeah man so I say yeah so what
we had the manager Lisa as far as a real
reg everything bro that what you were
doing accounting
get behind and we got the I I got it bro
I don't even know we're gonna sit boy
I get and I propose dude I was tired dog
we did the water pool podcast yeah did a
festival all things beautiful cake
quickly Kate Quigley it was tava how
late did you stay after that after the
show thank you by the way bro thank you
my sire said dog you know you were
nervous I was nervous as hell done you
would notice how Dave dogs hell yeah we
wonder what's going down with merely
until your lady broke up I thought this
was a battle ready bro but they hit him
you know the whole battle ready
everybody's there you know you any
haters do by himself like he was about
to hit or no-hitter but you know what
how killed doc Thank You doc you know
you did right yeah yeah it just you
won't be heard of when I came up to you
afterward right yeah you want to be
humble you know but set your little
jokes cuz sometimes you think you know
you're not relevant in the comedy world
I don't only of this crowd yeah judge my
writing but yeah good the only thing
they sucked about that nothing talked
about the set but when I walked off I
slammed my my finger got slammed in the
door oh my god but I held that [ __ ] in
like a soldier but I stayed till about
2:00 a.m. and then I went home I went
home back to the hotel then took off
yeah we happy yeah it was cool right now
people are coming up taking photos it
was tight dawg it was true though that
big dogs are hell yeah dude but you know
what's cool too dog
Brent Weinbach dogs talking about little
fool dog he went up yeah he was yet he
would have put on another show or he
know he went up on that show he did he
went up on that show I was talking that
fool Ari who else
full tron photos cool huh yeah cool as
hell look they keep surreal that suit oh
yeah AUD a dog you know who was funny
Lisa was there though dude - Jason - you
bought dog he was doing good as a
precious of detail right dog and that
other fool Tony he was killing us in the
background this ain't [ __ ] they would
say he would know he was saying [ __ ] he
would say but it was that Jason tee ball
right yeah oh my god dude was killing us
dog really nice dude funny as she does
though she was with bingo yeah bingo
yeah you said what's up to him they came
in dude I was tight dude I totally
forgot about that one dude those cool
man or so it was all happy bro who fool
Richie Richie Brian rich again
also pluck in season Brody was their
brother next day oh yeah yes right here
you got it well perhaps and he is here
right now Stephen Brody Stephens Felipe
Esparza you got it here we go let's go
it's time for her Brody Stephens it's
time for right here originally from New
Mexico according to his wikipedia that's
where my grandmother was born May 2nd
1909 pioneering the Hebrews of the
Southwest yeah I was at the festival
also thanks for having me here thanks
for yeah that was cool wasn't it out in
Phoenix they did a good job on bitchin
dude oh yeah man they did a good job it
was organized you know I look at a
festival today the shuttle buses on time
and they did you know some of these
these kids they put put together these
festivals nobody knows what's going on
you know all things comedy professional
they get it organized it was close I
enjoyed my time there yeah man did you
or did you steal it to a Sunday I stayed
until Monday I extend it I'm in no rush
you just got here
yes I run into Ari he say he's gonna
steal it so Sunday and then go to the
Grand Canyon yeah I'm just gonna go
hiking with like Steve Simone or
something yeah man I sometimes matter
was you had the time to do all that [ __ ]
man but I gotta feed the cat so if
you're the rabbit I had time but they
didn't invite me you know no I would
have I've never been to the Grand Canyon
either have I oh really
I mean have I cuz I'm when we had Tom
Green he um he was working at the laugh
out loud to uh stand-up live he said he
stood on Monday and went to drove to on
the desert to Sedona you took some
badass pictures over there and I never
been there either
but when I do go there I'm gonna be on
mushrooms yes the donor that's the way
to go that's a vortex have you been
there I've driven through but it's red
right there usual means a lot of
energies there they say like it's a like
I said it's like a vortex Joshua Tree or
maybe even more so they say it's like a
magnetic
actually something in the mineral
vanilla minerals the rocks the placement
under the stars you know they also say
like Santa Fe or Taos New Mexico it's
like how's Taos New Mexico and Sedona
they're very spiritual there's something
going on there in a good way but you
should drill through their brewery for
your set yeah man he showed up I don't
know most families had a bad mood he was
in a zone or what he like he like you
were more nervous than doubt the roush
for Game seven the big show okay which
show were you on the night show the last
one that's one of the night with me
because I went up before him and you
know the first show we done with I go
before him right right so the pressure
was on yeah and there was a lot of good
comic stuff but it was good yeah the
crowd already huh walked up already
yeah that Ian Edwards was on the show
too and it was like yeah it was cool was
it at Tempe improv or stand up like
Santa blood oh that's a big place was
it's like it's packed and yeah they
wanted I feel like Phoenix is they want
to laugh they just want to know and
those audiences through the podcast and
they came out there like right I had
good sets also but didn't do the end of
the show oh yeah
who closed who closed the show at the
end yeah yeah cuz he went on for a
minute
fun right so you met a lot you got to
hang out with Tebow and I'll get to say
you hung out with Dean but it was there
I guess with smoke in a green room huh
yeah I'm straight edge I don't do that
no ever guide you I'm kidding I mean
it's the law it's a law to smoke pot and
have a North Face jacket in California
more like New York you go has one though
yeah that was like you know a little
little get up on to that in 2010 yeah
but that was um that was tight man I
don't know I knew there was opens up all
right I don't know that was it do those
first festival I ever been a part of
dude really
yeah now it was also happy took two
ladders funny
so it was like your first diverse ever
being a part of like a real festival so
how many people asking you how did you
get in there
haha do you say and honestly yeah yeah I
get it podcast with Felipe you did we
did Brea
you're on that show it's like I didn't
think when I saw I knew you were there I
didn't like go what is he doing here
I just assumed like you know I pick up
on energies I know what's up you know
like Felipe we get it
we've been to Dodger Stadium we're not
afraid to mix it up Public Schools LA's
we've been here through our ups and
downs but I I just I've done a lot of
these festivals I know these guys it's
like was your friend first festival my
worst best of a better see what happened
no I mean I've done picked up by a cook
I've done huh no I've done like you know
you early on if I get them going you
know I'm there in the early stages the
first year the second year and then it
gets popular then I get pushed aside but
you know I've done Moontower than
Montreal you see they get boots aside
yeah it happens hey Dutch you know I
always tell people like no I wouldn't a
beginning on say I'm yeah man people
should I find a comedian man but only
300 Oh
so with 5,000 you would have got mercy
all right you forgot about Felipe
slashing pressure side how about you
give me 600 because of the deal Oh
straight into venmo I always ask for
double what do you want man did I ask
for five then they go bet you to meet
him at the middle I mean with the
middleman so you I I don't I don't wanna
get all in the business but I need to
negotiate better and get somebody you
know I'm like what do you want
and even so do you DS you to be paid at
least fifteen bucks like that's what
they do at the Comedy Store
nah man $50 okay I go okay into town and
in town anywhere any spot and his bar
should be a hundred forty Brody you got
it well you know I think it's calm or I
think it's common knowledge like the
Comedy Store everybody knows you do a
regular spot in the original room it's
now 20 bucks a spot I think that's
common knowledge I don't want to talk
you know about like left us just 35 I
know that improves to be 15 when the
latwon when the common storm was 25 the
emperor was 15
improv now you do it
it's cash and it's anywhere from like
eight thirteen dollars it's always some
like weird and fifty-eight again you
change and it meets cash for the meter
huh yeah I mean yeah cuz you can't park
in Fred Segal anymore you gotta go find
parking and but I mean I like I like the
improv and I think that the Comedy Store
the other good thing about the Comedy
Store they're doing you know the main
room at you actually get and this is
common knowledge also a cut of the door
half so that well yeah that's what I
shoulda no she ate right 1/2 RI I cancel
and I walk out on my small deal I go I
walked out but the Comedy Store you play
there right you come by it's it's it's
they treat the comedians right you know
I've done a couple of the other not
couple I did a another Club and it's
just a little too corporate it's a
little too official it's you got you
have to confirm you got to do this you
can't do that it's like Comedy Store you
call in you do your spots boom it's like
you're treated like an adult and I think
that shows and why it's popular why they
want to hang out you want to say these
other clubs like and they try to copy
the Comedy Store you see them on social
media and all that they try and copy
which is fine but you got to be organic
and natural yeah in the comedian's pick
up on that and that's why they're drawn
and that's a big part of it to the
Comedy Store cuz you got some organic
guys who were like feeling it out and
bringing in the right vibe what do you
think about that well said oh thank you
can I get a recording of that that was a
telecom but I don't like like if you
call again for spots what she you have
to confirm because you're recalling yank
of calling is confirming let's give my
time oh yeah was by 11:45 can you come
and you got a confirm or the or I wanna
check home two weeks later you got that
right
oh yeah you know why after you go out
with the girl when she calls you two
weeks later not telling you go when you
go out to do a comedy spine to give you
a check for two weeks later oh they do
that you don't get paid that same day or
night I don't know those shows is that a
certain someone know cuz that you know
I've only been a couple times like
screwed on money and I just took a
chalked it up as experience their
clothes in LA you won't do
I mean I won't do urban clubs that's a
known fact no I'm kidding
um I'm Joe hello hello no that no that
no I'm Joe I would
III cuz I'll do are their clothes I
won't do no I'm open I mean some rooms
are probably a little more nervous I
mean than others like I'll do them all I
mean I do the Comedy Store do the Improv
I've done the alternative rooms for me I
like I go into these alternative rooms
with these kids and you can kind of like
lay into them you know cuz they come to
LA a lot of them want to be in show
business or be around it and it's I grew
up here you know I grew up in the valley
I've also been able to work in these TV
shows that they like it's so it's like I
know their secrets so you can go right
at them I don't do it with venom but you
go right at these kids and so those
those are the fun alternative rooms and
you do the Comedy Store and it's a
little you got to kind of like read the
crowd a little bit you know it's a
bigger night it's like I'm a comedy
store now is almost like the you know
the Magic Castle it's almost it's gotten
popular but it's still edgy which is
good I just hope they don't lose that
that edginess with their popularity you
know that's always a fear young men stop
putting in stars but I want to do I did
I don't know what the I want to go and
expand and do Orange County and do the
row Abdo do these cool gigs I like to
mix it up I've done so much audience
warm up and I've done a lot of crazy
hostel bars show so I'm not I'm not like
I don't do that I'm afraid because
people used to be afraid to the Comedy
Store back in the day and it's like I
was a regular you know past since like
2000 so I was it's like all the same to
me I you know I I you were there during
the little dark time before it started
popping now right yeah yeah I was there
through yeah all those times but for me
I kind of you know I did so much late
night I kind of road above the early
drama whatever there was going on with
those earlier spots and I would do my
late night stuff mixing it up at the
crowd drumming with Don Barris and just
but we kind of had a run of the place
not that the comedian's don't still get
to do what they want but it was really
like a lot of it could have been better
they could have done it better like we
they should do a better job of promoting
this important than once social media
came around got a good guy Breton doing
that and you know Rogan and these guys
coming back and Adam it was just like a
perfect mix and hopefully you know it
keeps going and the show's expand like
why not bring in more shows more guys
and hopefully The Improv or they'll
they'll pick maybe they won't maybe
it'll never learn
I don't know so why not just keep more
shows that's right man there was no
promotion back then huh huh none right
how many tears at the laugh at you per
for anything nothing new just a
particular they were depending they were
the laughter drew depending on Jay Davis
to have a show every night yeah it was
it was like though young comrades that
were packing the room on college night
you know I'm Ben Gleib with comedy Jews
then and then um Joe Torre with his fat
Tuesdays oh yeah you know man those guys
those chameleons were actually promoting
their own shows you know it wasn't the
comedy clip or more in their shows they
were packed because they were like I
didn't know their guy Chris Martinez
from the Laugh Factory I do tonight this
guy was actually well going into clubs
and in the parking lot a man got three
tickets to Laugh Factory and lying to
them that job was gonna be there so we
had a packed Latino Miami promoting
ourselves but didn't [ __ ] but the laughs
not one banner on stage come watch
Latino night oh yeah
but they only wanted one but they were
popping on the weekends for you know
they they did alright on Fridays oh
that's Rick hacked on Friday because I'm
Dan cool show up and do that an hour so
where was that crowd coming from the
danger crowd all over the valley there
come to work there were there were I'm
coming in from Jay Davis room they were
growing up watching Dane Cook at
Dublin's and then watching here man I'm
watching him at the Laugh Factory with
Jay Davis shows and then I'm Scott on
Skylar stone shows they were very
popular they were popular
there were fellow celebrities because if
you like it like when we released our
man without was waitressing at the Laugh
Factory on chocolate sundaes uh-huh
dude girls just showed up looking for
that money for those stars yeah cuz one
of the Lakers started showing up
hot hot tar model looking black girls
would show up and they wouldn't bite
nothing Callisto tell me they want they
don't you order stuff and then wait for
someone to pay for it let's just ignore
her I'm its bills gonna be $79 okay just
leave it right there
wait the Laker guys would come in and
yeah they would not Fisher was their
football player who did they they were
cool not cool Randy around Roku didn't
the other members they were out of
control yeah do a lot of pretty girls
there man a lot of cheating
Oh cheating from comics and it was you
know sometimes I had to stand up so
crazy that you know like on most nights
every comic gets to hang out in the
hallway by the bathroom and if you had a
good set you come on this I would do it
I will have awesome set then I will look
around the audience and never see
someone I like I wait for them to clean
up and go to a bathroom and then I'll
catch them come another bathroom at the
same time I'm coming about oh wow you
were funny oh yeah I know that right by
the locker so yeah bro to you Beast
Lisa anyway so but our chocolate sundae
though where we rose that show doesn't
let Khomeini's hang out right there bro
Oh
other common gotta go upstairs so the
host gets the first dibs
oh man and then they send everybody else
upstairs you get the top shelf so that
is it a whole different vibe on say like
the chocolate Tuesdays or whatever the
night they're a little is it al at night
and then either urban the urban nights
not necessarily it's more like an event
it's like they promote hard-on
under social media and you get all types
of african-americans there Ethiopian
real Africans you know people people
from South Central people in the valley
people from out-of-state people fly into
that show and how are the the crowds
like towards say somebody like me now
that now if you were to ask Brody are
you nervous about I don't know the
questions like if you're nervous they're
gonna say nervous I know that I give up
so what do I gotta do come at him hard
come at the crowd about them real and be
yourself man scare don't chuck and jive
to them just tell a man if you wanna
tell him that you're afraid to be there
you were your first line they're gonna
eat it up and laugh man and then use of
poor ago you all rise TV you just do
your thing
yeah you're right I know those guys and
I end up doing okay you know I that's
the thing like I've done so many is that
what you're doing bad lady will go like
only were some they was bombing bad
uh-oh and the same woman said somebody
help him oh I can see that happening oh
my gosh
that's all she just saved somebody helps
how about them Lakers you know I I they
I've done so much audience warm-up for
you know here for the Fox 4 to the only
word game and so you're thrown in you
know you're getting audiences from inner
city out you have no choice you know
it's your job you're doing warm-up so
it's like and I just that crowds urban
crowds will say they like it when I act
like cocky and like I played sports you
don't talk to me my friend always told
that they like to fake confidence I mean
it's confidence but it's they like to be
talked to you know not afraid and same
thing kind of with like seriousness I'd
get these you know I got every high
school everything but low say every like
high school and the football teams the
baseball teams and the basketball teams
and they're like looking to be coach
they're looking to be they liked it when
I got on them for like not sitting up
for not being supportive and then I
would do my pitching motions it's like I
would take that Sports attitude into the
audience warm up and now with like
comedy take I take elements of that you
know
pintu the stage a little bit yeah you
know learning about energy it really is
like energy and you know but not beating
the audience you go to a comedy club you
can't make them sit up but you can joke
about it whereas like when I do this the
TV shows like I can make you sit up you
know what I mean so you find but you
learn just about energies groups and I
was like lucky to be able to do all
those warm-ups and work with all the
different schools and in you know all
different groups of people and they're
all people they all but they have you
bring you bring the positive you bring
it you know eventually they might take a
minute or two to come around but then
they come around and you know that's
what I always feel that's what I do bro
to the high school bro who's that who's
that there's some guy that we know him
as it's comedian man he started off in
the Latin scene back in the 90s late 90s
but now he's doing motivational speaking
in colleges Oh get me into that I'm
serious you just just watching you speak
oh you're you're really more um more
credible now other guy were talking
about yeah how many followers does he
have an Instagram beat him up okay then
you let me get a stick let me get his
contact the National Council of La Raza
I've heard a lot but um you um so you
grew up in LA man you would you know you
could tell you you've been to sports
yeah I just like baseball baseball I was
you know back in Little League
Little League Tarzana literally that
[ __ ] I had a good arm did you
lure the Bad News Bears to I
oh yeah like the bad love those bad news
I like the original one we two wrong one
that was I love baseball bro like when I
was a little kid I have to watch
everything that baby I used to watch is
this weekend baseball that's right
and I have to watch Dodger dugout
channel 11 yes right before the game
started to watch the Dodger
postgame show I have to watch the show
before the shows and as to what that guy
the [ __ ] sports machine join Michaels
George Michaels Michaels this
I get pre-internet pre-major case all
Linum man like I'm nice to one hang out
bro like I knew a guy named Lomond
repose Lamont repos he's dead now oh but
that guy was a legend in the projects
bro this guy like a badass bass man
he was badass he loved the Dodgers so
much so he was [ __ ] you always sneak
into a stadium and man I see pictures of
him with Tom needing for your bro and no
t-shirt on are you serious like they're
holding a meeting for yours who had no
shirt on the can't even feel ok then it
all right well it's kind of strange but
I need to come home with bad spy stole
oh so he make it all the way dude we
used to sneak in the Dodger Stadium I
knew which way well just how cuz where'd
you go those king of sneaking it only
snuck on once but I had a ticket I just
didn't I just walked by him real fast
without your stadium I knew that's you
know my friend was a batboy so I had
sometimes we just sneak in to sneak in
like we just see how far we could push
it right but we used to sneak into the
forum for Laker Celtic games it was easy
like you go in and then you slipped you
get the the ticket stub like you're
gonna go outside and smoke the cigarette
and they put like and they're right on
your ticket so then you'd get a friend a
ticket stub you're right on the tick and
you both go in so we snuck into like
thinkers armed twice it was easy to
sneak in everybody would sneak into the
forum and and the Celtics the Lakers I
was a huge thing but I think this with
the Dodgers right now in the World
Series this is bigger I think it's this
biggest Showtime Lakers it's been
definitely bigger than like Kobe Shaq
Lakers oh yeah the LA the Dodgers
specially going to the seventh game - it
brings everybody together the Latin
community
you've got the Asian community you even
got the Persian community
you got Iranians with you dark yu
darvish you got Beverly Hills in Encino
into it this is international people
like the Dodgers the energy they feed
off the crowd always three million and
this is uh I think this is good for
everybody
what's happening oh yeah bro so when I
got invited like who's gonna turn down
game five tickets bro oh hell no and
then I didn't know was gonna sit and do
it I was I was tired bro cuz I wouldn't
step back three hours and four hours a
night something to make us to fly the
next day
and I was like it's the times and know
that so I still for hours one night for
the next night for over the next night
12 hour when I got to the name when I
got to the show when I got to a Phoenix
bro dude it was like baseball fever and
brother my hotel room bros the other
scalper from Los Angeles were scalping
tickets outside of my hotel room are you
serious all of them shut out to Mike G
tickets
he got 300 tickets to sell today wait
300 tickets he's got free she has to be
on a ticket for Game five Game six and
seven and here two extra one for me
brought you sitting up front like right
behind home plate but I gotta I gotta
leave my wife hanging by herself she lab
Arizona you're some nachos I'm gonna
take couple quick where'd you sit in
Houston all dude I didn't know we're
gonna see it how i sat on the second row
behind a Dodger dog
are you serious second row he was on TV
yeah Lopez Lopez invited me do you get
some good pictures oh hell yeah man and
I made a video man some people man have
to mortgage their home for World Series
tickets I had to just give up my kidney
to George Lopez yeah he needed that yeah
and man back to the lane we were right
behind home plate right behind the
Dodgers oh and I was sitting next to
Jose Cruz jr. bro please Jose Cruz his
father played Jose Cruz the original one
pick on the slaves for the Astros and I
was sitting there with Jose Cruz jr. he
played for the Dodger maybe at two
months or a year yeah and he's a
baseball analyst right now and he knew
exactly how many home runs it was before
he break the record for most home runs
in the World Series
yeah and his kids were there his son got
drafted but he's gonna finish off is his
uh
rise he paid for a university Jose Cruz
jr. yes sir I played baseball Arizona
State University my first game wrapped
it I wasn't drafted I would have been
but at the university yeah yeah
Scottsdale I earned 110 days Tempe all
right be done to the team bro the first
little fuck-around that's right the
first game I ever started
was in 1990 the team I faced Rice
University yeah he was on the team they
blues junior you got it
face them forgot what he did probably
got a hit but dude I pitched I'm pretty
sure I faced him but I'd faced rice it
was my first victory Fernando vino was
our second baseman went on to play like
11 years in the major leagues Paul lo
Duca later on who was with the Dodgers
too but yeah I pitch I beat UCLA I beat
Rice I beat Lubbock Christian I we went
to the College World Series and coach
first base
so I've done a lot of baseball and yeah
it's in my blood you know I love playing
catch I love throwing the ball and I'll
judge a comedian on how they throw you
know oh you talk tough there's a ball
here's a glove okay let me see how you
throw oh you feel pretty good now let's
see how you catch it are you afraid of
the ball you want those guys who moves
out of the way do you like move that are
you hide behind your glove that's what I
look at so I play baseball I starts to
be abroad he actually broke and Latasha
Leggero and I forgot who else was there
too and we were at when I threw out the
first pitch at Dodger Stadium oh yeah
yeah yeah that was like yeah that's
quite a while ago yeah used to work at
Dodger Stadium yeah I saw a fool I went
there man and guess who stood there man
George guerilla George always lies yeah
that's a fool that [ __ ] um my friend
Ivan Gabriel system we were all working
with I work at Dodger Stadium yeah which
work yoshino here because they brought
in Yoshi no yeah because head down no
more showed-up
they do that doing a lot Japanese
customer so they gotta make sure
Yoshi no you know he's got a good
podcast no no she oh okay
Yoshi no I got it got it Yoshi right
there the poor guy I remember Yoshi man
he went he went I'm [ __ ] what you want
he wants if he wants to do a stead at my
show I walk coyotes
I say yeah bring any poor another put
you up even 20 so I've known Yoshi
since like 94 when I moved up to Seattle
so yo she was up there Josh
wolf Joey Diaz threat cuts the rider
back Craig Gass and then our friend Tina
who worked in the adult video store he
worked in taboo video so Tina was the
original guy and Yoshi came into work at
taboo video and that's how Yoshi got all
into porn up in Seattle then he moved
down to LA but it was also up in Seattle
so I went to hang out with the Yankees
my friend was a coach with the Yankees
somebody I knew so I'd hang out with the
Yankees and then I would give porn to
the Yankees this is back in the day when
it was all DVD so like Jason Giambi and
all I mean he would talk about if I [ __ ]
who the best throw at our bra I'd burn
West Covina huh Yoshi yeah yeah yo she
would give me boxes of porn to give to
the Yankees they needed it and it helped
them look at they want all those World
Series because they had to release it so
oh Joe exactly and but now it's all
online but that's the connection a Yoshi
just helping out Major League Baseball
behind the scenes well he had polo here
regular for those chicks no and then
I'll keep him with my Frigidaire but
there were my ladies broke yeah like
that a whole crazy-ass European porn -
all that [ __ ] oh yeah I still got there
they're classic like ya know but he had
everything and you know she's like made
a name for himself he knows and you know
she's another guy just to go get her a
good guy positive energy and oh he's
like I think there's like two of them
he's like there's he's always in Europe
he's always in always traveling dude
always traveling and then he's got an ax
then you say Yoshi what do you been up
to oh I've been up in Sylmar I mean what
I thought you're like all over the world
so but he was he was the inside porn guy
for major league baseball and I don't
think I'd really comment - yeah it would
be handed in those things that like
candy who saved a lot of lives I mean
these guys you know I don't need I don't
need any issue I'll go home pop in the
DVD
it was cassettes - also I just got a bum
you'll should give me VD
yeah I got depressed it helped with
depression instead of like
antidepressants he would just give you a
DVD you'll feel better and what happened
when that dude used to work with that
George guy George Lutz oh that guy still
working there bro an animal George
Jodoin a better guy that my friend I'm
Iran who works we gave him is enough cut
his hair for a $10
I love it we're a beanie bro he [ __ ]
up in here anyway so after I'm thinking
like after the game right now I'm
sitting there with a bunch of our Astros
fans and I'm George I've been to every
every game he went to all seven games
uh-huh and um I'm a funny man cousin
they're not used to seeing someone crazy
who I represent pavilion bro
I cheer like I'm a leper Billy you then
feel pavilion bro so when the astronaut
airing you know that the thing that
someone struck out I stood up and I
looked back and said what's the score
Astros somebody tell me the score please
tell me the score I don't know I can't
look back cuz I don't wait for zero at
the time uh-huh you're saying that yeah
were they and what did they say stuff
back then I denied your silence how loud
was it Astro it was loud bro but it was
not that low Ray was daddy
they were happy though mother really
they were loud and man I never said that
close bro I was going that way now every
time it does you will come back when
they were losing I would say good job
guys good job they were watching me I
think you see my hand though would they
look up at you I was crazy bro does
George know the guys like do they see
George I like ik now man after the game
I thought we were going to go home you
know I'm gonna go home no smoking look
anyways before we come on man shoutout
to ash from Houston up we'll pick me up
are you serious he picked me up bro
drove me around the city he took care of
me I went to a Chinese food with him it
was amazing then he picked me up after
the game and we hung out again it's
better than an uber driver better man
personal fool George's friends was Nate
Diaz no oh the wrestler yumpire Oh Lance
Diaz Laz Diaz yeah yeah yeah I know
land lands huh yeah last year something
like last year's the Puerto Rican to the
umpire yeah so man dude after the game
of tomboy homes we're waiting the game's
over man
so Paul George goes hey man we're gonna
go hang out with umpires I think what
leave me hanging with the umpires he
goes no they have their own green room
downstairs so we want you took the
elevator bro
I'm there with the umpires families bro
and we're eating dog we're eating food
or food is [ __ ] hanging out but the
whole time man I'm gonna get the umpire
man I want to ask now what something bad
no that's right I don't want to say
nothing so after that we took a photo
with everybody I saw everybody my HBO
special we won't we all leaving but we
walked through the field oh my gosh you
got a photo with the umpire hell yeah
they're kicked corn bro I'm not gonna be
here again and I came out of NBC Sports
with Fred Roggin hey oh I heard yeah I
was by his interview
I'll even no bro I look like I look like
a creep looking for his car looking for
vegan dogs looking for pokemons looking
for a victory what are the odds that you
would be hanging out with a major league
baseball umpire in the hat that I'm
wearing today is a major league baseball
umpire hat never people don't wear these
never these are I'm with no way well I
believe in connections I believe in
energies and I've been around world
championships
I've been around winning baseball and I
learned that from the valley you know my
buddies won five World Series
championships he went to LA Unified he
went to taft he's been in not only won
because he was with the Yankees he was
with the Dodgers for four years who's
with the Cubs bottom line is who brew
Mike Borzello winning attitude blue
collar gets it pushing creating Kershaw
creating the cutter with Kenley Jansen
what I'm getting at is energy what are
the odds that we scheduled this podcast
for the game 7:00 a.m. 7:00 you work
there I I just put up a photo on my
Instagram though judo sprayed it you
sprayed it you work oh you worked on
grants crew oh you did working now
around the corner actually Western
Western like oh god yeah la Cucaracha oh
they have good chicken are they hiring
over there right now
because if you hiring bro you can maybe
use our zip pre-cooler recruiter I'm a
big guy now zip recruiter bros indoors
it's our sponsor this week
what if hiring could be easier more
streamlined and less time-consuming so
even when you're busy you can still be
smart about the way you hire instead of
hiring losers how zip recruiter is
different with zip recruiter you can
post your job to over 100 of the web's
leading job boards with just one click
you can rest easy knowing your job is
being seen by the right candidates how
many people you know that we have
businesses bro a lot a lot right then
zip recruiter puts a smart matching
technology to work actively notifying
qualified candidates about your job
within minutes of posting so you receive
the best possible matches you didn't get
to lie bro about your credentials or in
some jobs but I can't lie better huh
become somebody
no wonder 80% of employers who post on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site in just one day zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire right
now my listeners can post jobs on zip
recruiter for free that's right free
just go to zip recruiter comm /foo zip
recruiter dot-com /vu that's zip
recruiter comm slash for one more time
try it for free go to zip recruiter comm
slash full
Oh zip recruiter um I'm on it right now
you got people to hi Rose you go yeah
we'll have to let mando know dude
like I'm I'm pretty sure like you're
mando wouldn't use zip recruiter he'll
probably get a qualified Roach killer
right away bro that's no family members
that you gotta it sucks when you hire
family you're gonna steal my
Thanksgiving you know they're hungry
because you fire them you got companies
the lazy ass panorama city born Kaiser
you and I didn't open mic ones we did
we're at the arm in the valley of course
that were you from at the buzz cafe or
buzz something buzz it sounds familiar
yeah give an address we didn't open by
how long it must've been a long time
I'll tell May 1999 of some I believe
that yeah
was that on like Ventura Boulevard yeah
it's a Boulevard you the you there was
another guy but when I remind you the
joke last are you sending more than
yours
but I swear to god bro you're the one
who said it you said that one when you
went out stretch Martin's god where's
telling women you shouldn't be this fact
oh that's Tanner's line I did that it's
change or you're home with you were
there with Dana who's friends with
Yoshii yeah Dana was a funny guy you
know that's all I learned a lot about
like B he would open miking with that
guy maybe with him who said it yeah he
probably stole yeah I mean yeah I don't
know how that works no attainder didn't
steal but yeah we did uh open mikes up
in Seattle and you know like I said
that's where I learned go she and we
learned about just being I learned about
you know Justin Turner worked with the
same guy I work with about positive
words and I saw the results and then
when I went to Seattle I saw that hey
it's it's it works and it was this fun
it's fun to be positive we did cable
access you could say whatever you want
you could curse you could show nudity we
didn't show that Dana no we did like a
hundred and eighty live shows because we
thought it would be funny to be
different you know
so in Seattle is Seattle is prime for
like picking making fun of they like to
protest everything we came up and like
just shaking it up but after why you got
to get out of there get to New York
we did was so full of the awesome yes
ready for this game yes game seven
tonight Game seven man who's [ __ ]
Darvish Darvish persian persian asian
persian yeah by the time we're Asian but
a ton of air people will know the
results okay now Game seven
are you serious yeah was today okay Game
seven oh my gosh what's gonna happen bro
dude I'm going for a Dodger win dude
that's it man that's it man if someone
who asked you about where'd you go got
Game seven thinking right now show up is
there there would you do
oh say yes but I was already thinking
about going over there sneaking in
tonight oh no there's gonna be there's
gonna be like National Guard by yourself
a military officer outfit it's a man I
mean I was about to be holding a flag
[Laughter]
dress up like a maintenance guy Aimable
three cleaners grass there you go people
cuz you know what if you dressed up like
the lowest lowest job they have a Dodger
Stadium don't even look at your face
like you have a mop a mopper nobody
looks at him yeah you got a mom well the
last time you remember what the mob guy
look like man ever but you remember who
the security guy look like ah do you
remember what the [ __ ] cop look like
a security guard haircut huh you go mop
you go you go mop bro
how was security when you get it when
you were over there fool let me tell you
man you want to see Christina go to the
waywe a pop above Reserve it's a VIP
area and right there although there's a
warehouse door that's always open and
you could walk all the way down in my
last Eve know you are I know all the
little business and you couldn't hide
but you gonna you can't go all the way
out to we're gonna ask for a ticket you
gotta go stay on those for a while stay
on blue reserve for a while real chill
and then work your way down but I'll
tell you after 9/11 security changed and
now Dodger Stadium is just like there
are cameras everywhere you know they're
they'll be on you'll be like think
you're somewhere in like guy pops out
you can't be here and you know it's like
it's pretty hardcore now but it's worth
it I I think that they're watching bro
yes what there
there it's like Big Brother they kicked
out of this couple on the side of me and
last night I don't know why they kicked
them out and then Lee and then someone
told me that that want someone either
that woman husband or her grab that
Astros hat from somebody and threw it on
the Fila bro oh but I didn't see it
happen it was like they just graduated
[ __ ] here ma'am
well cameras everywhere Big Brother
there's a lot of Astral fans there's a
lot of orange in the in the crowds there
well you had that friend that worked
Dodger security and he said that uh on
every seat in Dodger Stadium they can
point a camera at you oh yeah there's
high-definition cameras they are on
glazed like six seven years
facial-recognition I mean they have
things like you can go on like on the
internet and type in your you know which
game you went to and you could zoom in
and see your face yeah I mean they're
doing everything and baseball now is me
with the technology these juice balls is
these it's like arena baseball people
like it it's quick it's I mean I don't
know if this will carry over to the
regular season you know maybe it's if
it's on there only into it for the World
Series but the pace of the game the
quickness the fans into it but even that
game one five hours the other night
seemed like three hours it's like it's
good it's good in my fast good wholesome
entertainment and we watched the whole
game hell yeah what does it say what's
up with the with the baseballs that
they're saying they're like they're
hitting a lot of too many home runs this
year so lighter or heavier or they wound
up tighter I think they're wound up a
little tighter
I think that's giving them that's true
because I'm one of the home runs that
that that was hit and um and I'm I'm in
the main field uh-huh the ball going
Tennessee's miles an hour bro 97 and I
got to walk through the field dawg I
mean that ball sword brother I was so
high he didn't even ever come down and
when it came down it was a homerun
I think I'm more maroon because that is
it that one Marvin Marvin yeah these uh
I think they're a little juice but you
know it's still I like it
you still got to get the guys out it's
for both teams and but this these games
are pretty exciting every one of my
mom's into it you got regular people
into it and it's Jays things into it bro
I don't even play baseball now oh yeah
after the game that who went to his rule
locked everything up brother you come
back outside mad the umpire bro are you
so terrible we ate together you know
what [ __ ] is dude I'm not seeing Dodger
flags around on cars I don't know I was
going to see more hats everybody has I
see one flat over here but man no flag
some of that somebody slept on that
hustle or what yeah I don't know mainly
made field Oh a lot of orange bro yeah
and I and I'm last night I saw some
patches of orange it seemed like there
was a lot like they travel their ass oh
god your fans travel too but shitload of
of Dodger fans in my hotel room bro
yeah but the Roscoe in Houston the raw
scalpers she's got me scalping
so I'm taking sin for 20 years remember
that one dude they'll turn instead of
that extra ticket for robbery for cake
for a lot of money
Oh is there a bro are you serious that
big old big fat little Quixote's yeah
because you start going to concerts a
lot or are those that you see that you
start recognizing the scalpers dude well
when I see a scalper he told me exactly
after the World Series they're gonna
rest for a day and they're gonna all fly
out somewhere in Oregon somewhere so
there's a sold-out Bruno Mars concert
and they have tickets for that really
trying to get Wango Tango let me uh I'm
you know I lived in Seattle I love to
work these right now I worked at sweepin
sweepin up with it I worked out I worked
on I worked in Seattle SuperSonics I
sold t-shirts there personick so I
worked in the team shop in the arena and
I'd sell the t-shirts and forgot what I
was saying
timeout Seattle copper's scalpers oh
yeah so there's this guy there this
asian guy who would always be kind of
like a weird looking guy but always be
scalping tickets at the game they're at
Key Arena in Seattle and then and he was
like he was shady cuz it was aliyah to
go back and forth then about like three
years later I was down on it maybe four
or five I was down in LA at the youth
hostel and he was staying there the
scalper guy he was in LA and he was like
surprised he recognized my face and I
said I was like what FBI it was like an
FBI bust and like free freaked out over
it it's crazy like but you just talk
about scalpers I happened to see him
like it is a racket these guys travel
around they're like carnival workers
they're in everything and I think they
get benefits
it's they get residuals 401k or 401k
it's a good deal you know there's a it's
there's options if you consider uber
maybe consider scalping these go these
guys know about the old school scalping
- man I'm back in the days and 80s in
90s when I'm just a Aussie was
performing and it was before I'm credit
card sales I was one of those kids bro
that they were someone who gave me a
shitload of cash and I'm standing line
breaking tickets for tech ticketmasters
music + and they say yeah bro
that fool Mike G ticket guy mentioned
music + studying right there bro with a
shitload of cash and buying 10 Ozzy
Osbourne a kids and then after I sold
out slagging oh [ __ ] we would scalp
tickets on Sundays we go with it with
the baseball camp Sunday games to Dodger
Stadium leave from Encino a bunch of
these uh you know a bunch of these
Jewish kids going the baseball game and
then the owner of the camp and have like
you know 50 leftover tickets you know
the blue level up there and he says you
got to go out and scalp them for
scalping tickets from the baseball camp
running around Dodger Stadium but it
would get it was different back then it
was like you know a little little I
remember the [ __ ] summer baseball cap
I wanted to go so bad
there were like 700 bucks for the whole
week you know just a little kid for the
housing project in the world I'm not
gonna pay for that [ __ ] she didn't pay
for my braces anyway so I wanted to go
so bad bro like it was like I remember
reading the pamphlet bro it was like it
was like a summer camp yeah it was 2
weeks bro yeah first day you could pick
what you want to work on conditioning
your arm you know stretching and base
running
and I remember I said yeah what I want
I'll feel lean man I was into baseball
but I wanted to play so good I remember
I'm Steve Brodie I had a I had a a book
that I got it was on how to pitch you
know how to hit hits yeah and how to
field and the whole book was about the
hope guess who was on the main cover
Harold Baines broke on the White Sox
left hand the whole book was White Sox
players really and they were telling you
like
position player on second never had
never hit the ball to third base you
gotta hit a first base that's why he
could get to touch the base he could run
a third get him over you know you know I
mean take the Machine yeah sacrifice
teamwork I always say about winning you
win you can get anything you want these
guys want individual you know people
want individual success but you win it
as a team
you're the Dodgers win the World Series
25 men on that roster they're heroes so
they're gonna have to never have to buy
a drink ever again it's like winning mad
or never bro and then within winning you
could be individual but people want to
put individual first
I mean baseball is individual but you
want to put that team you know I in the
word team because I am where is me got
it
but I try to like that's why I try to
help you win and it allows for freedoms
more more fun you know you got a but you
got to win like when I'm with the
Yankees like they expect the win it's
like corporate you know the Dodgers are
getting that way too they expect to win
I think they're gonna win tonight I'm
feeling it I'm not just being I'm
feeling it too bro I'm saying even a
Cardinal fan field yeah we're gonna push
this thing through it has to happen
because if it doesn't I'm gonna cause
problems to my wife purse they thought
Devil's Night and Detroit was bad wait
till I get started yes I was funny when
I was doing my Instagram video and I
wanted to see them these dumb Astros
fans and you're right bro everyone into
it they were East Indian probably and I
asked her mom what's gonna happen
tonight we're gonna get stabbed he said
oh yeah they're prepared know
everybody's into it I doesn't lose do
not yeah Astros in front of their face
on the way out oh yeah yeah I gave it to
you right now you're Astro fan if you're
from Houston do not cheer on the way out
in front of a Dodger fan tuck in your
feet because now you're you're asking
for problem the game's over already
oh you're already thinking the law I
don't even go I wouldn't go there
visualize positivity visualize that as
win but they should put you know yes
worst-case scenario the Dodger if you
guys win man
rip every Jersey or Jersey can find I
think both fan bases are pretty I mean
because we're select each other I think
we can we're both the Astros are so new
at this that the first time here there's
not really no rivalry just like good
competitive bright right
yeah there's those and the games are
good too good at least aJE's walks you
know walks it's back and forth it's
drama it's not quitting just when you
think it's bad drama dude you just got
to get up and that's what baseball
teaches you dealing with failure like
you just think it's done and you get it
going and then you'd like some losses
that's like the exciting part it's like
when you're pitching man like I'm
watching the when I was playing I'm MLB
game I'm my video game and I thought
like you know like okay I'm just gonna
be throwing you know the baseball game
it's gonna be throwing right most video
games you know when you play a sports
game that the the team you're the player
played fatigues out you can see that his
energy level going down but on the
baseball I'm the pitchers point of view
when you're pitching me know on the
video game it's more like real life Pro
like he's I give away two home runs and
you could see like in a video game them
his mentalness is leaving - yeah it's
not logical ah dude and you can see like
when it's red on the picture dude he's
not even throwing right he he don't has
a 90 miles an hour
man he's gonna get rocked it usually
happens that 90 pitch at 85 pitches yeah
they're bar they start getting fatigued
that's what I meant your pitcher Steve
was what the mental thought after two
back-to-back homeruns and those everyone
hurt your college is cheering for you
how you feel so they feel like bombing
or worse I think if it hurts like I'll
never play again I suck I remember I
give I go oh I stink but you got a bet
you got a bet it depends are they two
single shot home runs or they like bombs
if you give up like you like to single
shot you know one run solo shots
I could battle back from
but if you're getting like clobbered it
is kind of demoralizing but you know you
know you got hopefully these guys will
back up but I would pitch I'd visualize
I'd get strong or like towards the end
like I could smell that victory line and
I pitch a lot of nine inning games I
struck out a lot of guys because I'd
read their Energy's like I'd take it
personally though you're diggin it on me
I'm gonna strike you out or I'm gonna
bust a curveball on you so I would give
a great effort but I wasn't like sigh
young why we like ate up innings but
there was times I like could really like
dig in and get passionate you know I
could pitch angry I can't do comedy
angry so pitchy and angry get that arm
that adrenaline get gonna get that
5-hour energy into you boom I take it
personal but comedy you got to kind of
like be a little more finesse but then
some pictures could pitch finesse - can
you hit - just pitch I had good power I
hit some bombs in high school but when I
went to college I really didn't work so
much on my hitting I didn't put the time
and I don't know if I ever would have
been in college hitter but I was
definitely a pitcher good arm but I had
bad mechanics the way I threw I kind of
put extra strain on my elbow but and
then bathed you know college it's like
it's a big step up call it from high
school to college so my body I really
started like amping it up and if you
have bad mechanics you put you know
strain on an elbow or a shoulder and so
I put that strain but ever since then
I've studied mechanics to where I'm 48 I
could still throw and people say like
could you miss playing baseball but it's
like I don't need to play major league I
just like being around it I could play
catch with a major leaguer in the
offseason there's so many avenues in
baseball if you love playing baseball
and you love you can find a job it
doesn't always have to be major leagues
you know so oh the affair pitch you
threw fastball again like how fast I got
clocked at 91 in college I I did I swear
to gosh I have videos on YouTube I video
some videos I threw hard I hit with
passion high school high school probably
through like mid to upper 80s
that's so good oh yeah that's faster
than you did in high school
two kids throwing names oh yeah now
that's like normal yeah I think it's
same looking kid because they have daily
roids well no they have better training
tools now they all have the you know
surgical tubing they all have the little
year-round baseball and they have these
exercises that really fine-tune your
fast twitch muscles and it's and that's
why you've seen these guys these little
these little guys hitting bombs and
running around like how do they do it
like Altuve or Bregman or you know
Austin Barnes with the Dodgers it's
because they fine-tune those little
muscles and these training tools were
back in the day was like just show up
now they've got like okay 5-hour energy
protein greens that stuff is more
accessible now too
it's more accessible it's all monitored
and it's you know fine-tuning you see
these guys now it's like I think a lot
of these soccer that's another thing
like you got it's like it's an athletic
game now and it's quick the second bait
there's flavor like Baez with the Cubs
and you know Seger's it's it's exciting
game to watch right now Bellinger I mean
I like watching that guy play he's like
so he's so confidence like he's been
there he's cocky but not unlikable he's
I don't know if he's cocky but he's got
confidence you know I like watching Puig
Puig is fun he's emotional sometimes you
know he doesn't hustle he gets hard he's
hard on himself but you can tell he
cares you know you got to have a guy who
cares and I think these Dodger guys they
you know they they put that passion out
even though they're like they have
unlimited budget it's LA it's all glitzy
these guys really do care and so that's
a good you know Dave Roberts does a good
job with dad and the coaching staff
people don't realize how important a
coaching staff is because you get these
guys in the front office or like telling
them what to do and then they they hand
it off it's up to the coaches to kind of
take that information and explain it to
the player and talk to them so they're
these players don't like getting told
what to do by guys who never played
baseball you know you're in the front
office you study the the stats but if
you get a baseball guy who played
baseball and the understands the stats
and he can communicate you know you got
you have like a Dominican catcher who
has to deal with some guy from Texas
like there's like even a Japanese guy
you got different personalities and it's
up to the coach to kind of like that's
why Phil Jackson was a great coach or
Joe Torre there's something about
coaches do matter and that's not
physical that's mental that's energy
that's that's wisdom I think and I think
the Dodgers have done that would good
job with that balance where they're like
unlimited resources but they get to play
into that you know that energy to play
off the fans and fans matter
well yeah it's finally coming together
perfectly you know these Dodger fans you
know they talk about Chris you know it's
Chris Taylor was saying last night we
feed off the fans that's why you know
Seattle you know maybe they don't you
know these fans they don't look dead
yeah they're dead you're not into it
they're angry you know what I mean the
cabin that you like the oak cut to Tom
slick yeah
Dodger fans get it but even look at San
Diego day they're not they're too laid
back down there they're too happy
whatever it is they're you know what
it's a nigga's it's a saltwater well I
know I think there's its military town
there's people from all over the country
that come to live there so what's the
real other than the connection maybe the
Chargers Big Frog rule what's big frogs
that'll work out no there's some big
frog the comedian from San Diego where
the podcast called big frog oh yeah I'm
gonna park a jeans love it was so cool
podcast speakers cracking I got dates
people I got dates a lot
also I'm hosting tropic area Music
Festival in Long Beach at Queen Mary's
Park November 11 November 22 I'm in
Midland Texas November 1 through a third
I'm in Ontario California but I'll show
that already sold out so yeah you know
it's
scalpers yeah you know someone 4217 up
here to a distant Improv in Addison
Texas check out Phillipos WorldCom slash
tour for our shows dates the rest of the
year which diverged ago chilling didn't
we watching the game in hello dates
podcast oh yeah man coming out tomorrow
it's been a while huh
yeah well the last one was last Tuesday
Stephen bloody here my podcast even
bloody is my friend I love so man I see
I see your hostel bro you know we don't
see each other a lot but I see what
you're doing out there bro I keep track
of everybody I saw you did the HBO
miniseries thank you I saw that it was
cool but I saw you as a [ __ ] cop on
the hangover yeah
see you on [ __ ] bro I pop up here and
there bro you're relevant Bri stay
relevant I tried to do yourself in there
every year keep people to let people
know Steve brought it around that's
right and also noting one time you take
your meds and all that what the [ __ ]
going on well you know what I got I got
blackballed you know I remember what was
going on you were in a bad mood I did
need backup
should we go [ __ ] go [ __ ] somebody up
for you what's going on man I was a
check right everybody I started off with
what they're doing but you know how
these Hollywood types are they pressure
you you know I'm blue-collar Valley and
they're trying to give me this you know
Hollywood Brentwood Westside the hills
of Satan energy I go I don't I don't
play that game so there were dinners
have lunch you know there's like I'll do
dinner and lunch but when you start like
I just felt like there was some conflict
there but I stick to my guns and that
that's that's what you know you learn
from it you learn from it what happened
bro well you know I was in a great mood
and I was fine and I went to I went to
Ireland and I wanted to like drink a
little bit so I said oh I read like oh
he could cut back I I'm not like a crazy
guy everyone needs like a little
something to take the edge off whether
its beer pot cocaine whatever so because
women because Facebook was stressful I
took a little bit of this lexapro common
normal thing it's like small dosages
it's supposedly take the edge off so
anyway on that
went to Dublin I heard oh I've never
been out of the country maybe I'll drink
a little bit somebody said oh if you cut
back you could drink a little bit so I
cut back drank a little bit things were
good and then I went to Montreal
straight from there and I got sick
really sick but I was feeling good but I
got sick probably from stopping the meds
that's the thing I cut down and like my
body like reacted to it but my shows
were great I was wide open I'm going hey
I feel great I'm happy but I was just
talking and then when I came back people
the whole Brody you're not acting
yourself I go I'm happy and they were
telling me take a victory lap have fun
because I was reserved
I'm very remember I hadn't had any
problems before and I haven't had any
problems since and the problems I do
have are usually audience warm-up
related you don't see me getting a
road-rage you don't see me getting
fights at the Comedy Store you don't see
me getting fights on a podcast you saw
it with audience warm-up you saw with me
having a show about me having these guys
who didn't play baseball maybe they're
not blue-collar and I'm trying to push
and there is just kind of like some time
I can go into it but I made a mistake
I'll say that maybe by take by going off
taking the Med down I was just a little
more sensitive and it was just a
combination of maybe the travel me doing
stuff and it wasn't it was just pushing
and I go effort you're gonna push me I'm
gonna push back so there's just a lot of
that energy and I feel like I learned my
lesson but I was I was I talk you happy
though you look happy
am i happy no back down off the meds
yeah I mean I believe me being off being
off I was open-minded I was like but I
could really get into it you know thing
could get my mind wandering and it was
kind of like I mean now I've been I know
how to handle myself now like if I take
a lot of caffeine or if I cut back I go
okay I know I'm cutting back or I know
I'm high you're like I'm more aware I
learned it's like don't don't touch the
hot stove I kind of touched it but I
also touched it
not knowing it wasn't like I made some I
mean I got sick I've got sick in
Montreal and he said I had strep throat
he gave me an antibiotic and my mind was
just like clear I may
it's clear but maybe that took time for
me to get adjusted but my friend saw oh
you're not acting yourself oh yeah I am
I'm doing great will you look yourself
and then they started like are you okay
and I go yeah I'm okay we don't think
you're okay
I go leave me the F alone man I mean
don't you get it and then it kind of
like spiral but once they started you
know poking at me I kind of poked back
kind of thing and then I put stuff on
Twitter you know like FPS go this is
before periscope but I did a video yeah
I did a video but you know what it was
just a learning experience maybe getting
out of my system but I think it was a
combination and I'm not blaming anybody
ultimately it's me and I did learn from
it and maybe others can learn from it
like can't stop meds cold turkey doesn't
mean yeah it doesn't mean you how to
break down it's just like somebody like
doing a ton of coke and getting it
that's the way I look at it was just a
big shock to my system so I didn't
really take it personally oh I can't
handle pressure you know you try to do
warm-up you try to but I can't handle
pressure but I feel like this was a
little I like doing periscope I like
doing stand-up because I kind of like do
my own thing when I'm better that way I
feel like Mike what I'm trying to you
know like no I wasn't trying to impress
anybody there I don't know it's such a
long time ago to be honest with you it's
like I kind of moved on from it but I'm
glad I went through it but it makes me
appreciate doing stand-up more I don't
want to do you know when you work with
others sometimes it's like you get into
that groupthink you start doing doing
things you wouldn't normally do to like
kind of go with you're influenced by
your friends I'll do that I'll do that
it's like I'm out of my comfort zone a
little bit
whereas I do my periscope you do your
podcast it's like you feel better it's
you you're not under crazy stress
hopefully and then people see you and
you're not that stress isn't bad but
they people see comedy see you in a good
mood and I like doing it so does it pay
my bills I don't know you know it's all
I'm all learning I'm all learning but
it's a crazy world now you know it's
it's always changing and you know I'm
older and then you feel like the
that business is changing the world
changing yeah the business is changing
the Dodgers are in the World Series all
this stuff Game seven baby yeah men I
have nobody in terms of blame I'm not a
blade I always put it back on myself
sometimes too much but I also feel like
I just need to light a fire and part of
this is doing these podcasts getting in
here I need structure on that baseball
guy if you like leave me alone yeah I'll
do a procrastinate but if I have
structure 162 games spring training
repetition 3000 warmups spots at the
Comedy Store I can kind of do that and
that's why I need a podcast and it all
comes around you put it out there I I
believe in that up to this point it's
gotten me you know my name out there I
don't have a house child girlfriend or
dog or Prius I don't have that but I
have in terms of like I know how
comedians treat me I know I like I like
it meaning like it feels good yeah I
know what feels good and what doesn't
feel good and if it didn't feel good I
wouldn't be around so I enjoy comedy and
thanks for having me these coming up I
well tonight I'll be at the Comedy Store
I might be doing Paris France I got a
check back again have you been to Paris
ever I've not been so I don't know I'm
gonna find out I'm doing a podcast also
on all things comedy it's kind of with
my friends too on that's on another
network I need to do that thank you for
that that's more that's long funeral
tough 200s you know I am yeah
I gotta follow I'm walking a lot off cuz
people do it enough people find that
about you and then you go search you out
and then you go through all the episodes
yeah I think if they're asking where's
the next one but it's always up well
they do you're in a tough 209 I need to
do just amazing because there's a
shitload of podcasts and you're being a
top 200 is good
no thank you you know I just feel like I
need is me I'm Steven is Steve Brodie my
friend t-shirts I do I you know where
that burns me friend it comes from like
I was uh when I was a waiter in New York
City had two Busboys mr. Lee who was
like a 70 year old Chinese guy and Tony
who's Albanian and mr. Lee would always
go Brody you go guy umifriend so it's
always like an homage same staying with
the same they would like my enjoy it
when I
in Tempe Arizona this was 1988 my
freshman year I would go I was like kind
of homesick and on Sundays I get the LA
Times and go to McDonald's and Tempe and
lady working at McDonald's was just
high-end or like positive energy she was
uh she was just like a happy Caucasian
lady and I would order my big man I'll
take a number one combo and then she'd
slide the you know the tray over and
she'd go enjoy and she was so excited
about it so then I would start saying
around the baseball team enjoy and then
you know the baseball guys picked up on
it that's where I learned a lot about
like wording and supportive like when
you're a teammate you got to be like
let's go Rodrigo need you buddy Big O
are pushing feliu you make it fun and I
just saw like the benefits of that so if
trying to harness it and you know
especially and everyone's so negative
and I I've shown that I just saw through
the warm-up when I when I was negative
energy or no energy lights would met
lights would go out or teleprompter
wouldn't work you could you know people
are afraid to like I would always say
like you got to take that the milk and
pour it in the Grape Nuts you can't like
half a you're gonna like go for it and
that's how I would do my warm-up and and
a lot of its just feedback you do stuff
you like okay and then you get a
comedian out protea like when you do
that and the valley stuff how do you
know what to say with somebody as I said
I'm with a bit of friend I talked her to
the audience like they tell you oh well
I see you go to I was just relieved in
high school I just throw it out there
I'm just lucky I mean I think I have a
home home city advantage here that this
to Jim Brogan bro oh yeah the famous guy
Jimmy Brogan yeah laughter and my wife
were watching she's that you know like
every high school coach well I think a
lot of that was you know playing
baseball receipt oh he would just study
I played high school sports so I knew
every he's right you know pretty much
where'd you go to high school which
worth of a high school okay Roosevelt
yeah they're red and I've told you that
they have like a red and yeah scarlet
they would come to the best damn sports
show
Roosevelt so I got every high school but
we would just study how you were the
best death Porsche listed with a good
show of the time which started all those
poor shows yeah it was down sports
was the show that started every ESPN Fox
for sure right no a reporter started
dressing up now before back then
reporter never dressed up comedy sports
and comedy and I loved it because I got
to meet so many athletes and so I go oh
I get to hang out John Salley right John
Salley John Kruk Chris Rose Rodney Peete
Michael Irvin Michael Strahan we started
Steven a Smith Mike Goldberg from UFC
just taught George Lopez Steve Harvey
Rose that husband who the main guy yeah
and Tom Arnold you know I was just lucky
I got to learn about yeah that energy
and I got to meet all these baseball
players and we had fun with the show and
a little bit of blood hell yeah but now
people talk about it they remember it
fondly where his back in the day was
like oh I can't find it when sit on it
so DirecTV now it's like people because
it's hard to replicate that stuff I
don't know maybe they're not that good I
don't know a lot more off the cuff
opinions and stuff on that second came
on was not scripted yeah say what you're
mad but and yeah tom was pushing it the
jokes were you know he pushed it was as
a knee goofy and then these other shows
started talking about it and a lot of
copycats him after that
hell yeah seems like everybody's form it
out for that now but I just like yeah
they're all are they be babies huh I
just love coming in like I look I go
who's gonna be here oh this guy this guy
this girl okay I get to take a photo
with him for cool and I write
so whenever was like I normally take a
photo but it was like a big time John
Salley get it like John Salley would
always take it for me and these guys are
good like Tom Arnold everyday broad
energy John Salley everyday nice guy
really was
Chris Rose the host professional just
you know you saw it and it was just fun
working and you know I took that same
energy I went to Chelsea Lately it kind
of I took out the sports and just hone
then took care of the comedians on there
and then same thing when I went to
@midnight
which just wrapped up at car I did that
the first two years
through that fake audiences you know
like the fake clapping or people being
timid or these VIPs acting too cool cuz
I've been up there I've been up on a
show like you say something funny you
keep the audience's now you're not
feeling it when I do warm up like I said
I can close my eyes and go we're good
let's do this and that's what I did to
take care of the comedian so again do I
listen I don't you know they say I like
when you do that valley stuff or I like
when you do that okay good I'll keep
doing that
so you just it's putting your raps in
there people what's the shortcut I mean
I think it's raps stage Shimon jokes
that's my thing stage joke stage time
and then right there it is people out
there who I want you how to do this
hi stage time and jokes I think that
right Brody I think so you're so full to
your podcast oh yeah well I've done
about 12 podcasts for we're gonna start
launching them here very soon it's a
sports it's a lifestyle nice it's if
you're 47 you rent an apartment in the
valley
you're a Caucasian male that I'm your
target podcast you want to listen to
mine yeah demographic it's my
demographic so I've been doing that and
yeah you can see me at the Comedy Store
a couple of times a week do the Laugh
Factory down a Long Beach and hopefully
doing some more you know independent
shows around town I like what you're
doing going out there I'd like to get
out on the road maybe give me some of
those Air Force bases
yeah be fun man was so full podcast with
Roger Torres right here and our super
guest all the way from the valley Dodger
fan well if I know a lot about him man
i'ma let you know they play baseball
never knew that receipt I wonder why he
stays in shape
everybody is fat I smash apple cider
vinegar I'm telling you I don't know
what it is but I'm I'm 200 pounds I
think you must even Brodie apple cider
yes vinegar
I was funny their coach was Regan